he spent eight hundred dollars on
star wars toys i'm hoping those are baby
yodas
and i want is a one baby yoda or is it
multiple baby yodos
and does this have anything to do with
your super fancy ironing board you told
us about
last year i'm very intrigued by your
spending habits
um so everyone please welcome
government stooge tommy thanks jared
uh so i'm tommy jones i'm a member of
the technical staff
at an organization called inquitel
inquitel is often described as the
venture capital arm of the cia
and if you ignore the fact that we're
not a venture capital firm and we're not
part of the cia
it's actually a fairly accurate
description of what we do
what we are as a non-profit strategic
investor and we invest in technology
startups on behalf
of u.s intelligence agencies but being a
non-profit
whenever these investments make money we
then reinvest those in initiatives that
further
our non-profit mission uh of public
service
one of those initiatives is be next
which is sort of like a biodefense
research organization and so i'm sure
you can imagine over the last
year uh almost uh they've been pretty
busy
uh with uh coronavirus stuff and so
since i'm a statistician by training
uh i got pulled into some of their work
and i'm here to present today
on uh some work in diagnostic testing
that i did with my bnex colleagues
so covet 19 testing has been all over
the news are we testing enough
who should get tested i'm not really
going to talk too much
about these things that you might have
been hearing about
i am going to talk about testing errors
however
i'm also going to talk about the fda's
emergency use authorization
so there's been an eua in place for
covet 19 diagnostic tests since about
february 4th of this year
and if you want to go research on these
tests what you would do is you would go
to the fda's website you would scroll to
find the test that you want
and then if there's particular
information about the test
say what uh sort of platforms it's
compatible with
or what sort of clinical evaluation data
did they report
you'd have to scroll through this pdf to
try and find that information and every
pdf is different because
the manufacturers themselves produce
them so they're non-standardized forms
so we built an application to help with
sort of
researching these tests i'm going to
talk about that
but first let's back up a little bit um
we'll start with a primer on covet 19
diagnostic testing just so we're all
sort of on the same page and then i'm
going to talk
about you know why tests fail why do we
get false positives why do we get false
negatives
before turning our attention to this
application that we built
the front end is in plotly dash the back
end
is at least for the calculations is
programmed in r
so there's three major types of
coronavirus test uh the first and most
common is the molecular pcr test you
probably heard a lot about it that's the
one where you get the
cotton swab shoved up your nose uh to
collect the sample
they ship that off to a lab for
processing
pcr tests measure the presence or
absence of the virus
directly by measuring the presence or
absence of viral rna
the other two types of tests are
antibody and antigen tests
i know there was a lot of press about
antibody tests particularly earlier in
the pandemic
we haven't heard as much about anagen
tests until the last
month or two i'd say and uh antigen
is a substance that's around uh uh the
virus that
induces an immune reaction and the
antibodies are that immune reaction so
antigen like pcr tests sort of measures
the presence
or absence of the virus by detecting
something directly on the virus
whereas antibody tests are indirect
they're measuring your body's reaction
in the presence of some sort of
infectious disease like
the coronavirus so pcr tests and antigen
tests can be used to diagnose current
infection
antibody tests are used to diagnose
recent past infection
uh they can in theory be used to
diagnose current infection but current
cdc guidance says that antibody
tests for coronavirus are not reliable
enough
to make such an important diagnosis
decision
you know the pcr tests and
antigen tests are also something that
can detect
the presence of the virus or or come
back positive sooner
because it can take the body a while to
ramp up its antibody reaction before
that can be detectable
but why do we do diagnostic tests
anyways
so in a clinical setting we probably
want to answer two questions
um or or one of two questions does the
person tested have the disease
or does the person tested not have the
disease
to answer the first question you need a
test with a high positive predictive
value
meaning if the test comes back positive
it's likely that the person has the
disease
and to answer the second you need a test
with a high negative predictive value
meaning if the test comes back negative
then it's likely the person doesn't have
the disease
and unfortunately a test can be good at
one and not so good at the other
or the test could be good at both but
the conditions and context in which
you're testing which i'll get to in a
little bit
can affect the accuracy of that test
so this third question about population
monitoring
is one that's incredibly important and
statistically fascinating
but it's also out of scope for my talk
so i'm just going to move on
but now we're going to turn to why tests
fail so why do we get false positives
why do we get false negatives
and i'm going to handle each of these in
turn
so this chart is got a lot going on
what it's plotting is over the cycle of
infection
for a particular patient that's on the
x-axis time
what is the likelihood that we might be
able to detect the presence
of whatever the substances this
coronavirus test is is
testing for and um
you know i'm not going to walk you
through every little line here but
needless to say you can get
false negatives even if you're uh you
have the virus
if you test too soon because there's
just not enough viral load to detect
or if you test too late in the infection
cycle because the again not
enough viral load to detect
another reason we can get false
negatives are
from poor sample collection so there may
you you may have the disease but uh
whatever
sample we took via the cotton swab or
blood or spit
there just wasn't enough viral load
there to be able to detect it
pcr tests seem to be particularly prone
to this as
uh you know that q-tip's just very
uncomfortable for you
it's very uncomfortable for the person
giving it to you
um cross-contamination is a reason you
can get false positive so
your sample may itself not have
any presence of the substance that
you're trying to detect but
it could be run through equipment that
does have that on there and so you can
get a positive result
from that but
when we turn to the statistics this is
where things get
a little bit more nebulous so first
there are four accuracy metrics to
measure how accurate a test is in
particular
circumstances right and they have four
distinct definitions
i already talked about the bottom two a
little bit although we'll come back to
them
but sensitivity and specificity are what
you're more likely to hear about when
people are talking about accuracy of
diagnostic tests
the reason for that is because
sensitivity and specificity are
calculated during some sort
of clinical evaluation of performance
and if they're measured well you know
they're just sort of immutable
characteristics of the test
this is how well the test performs given
these definitions
so we know what they are
but um if you remember from a few slides
ago
what i said was for the clinical
questions that we actually care about
for diagnostic testing
what we want are positive predictive
value and negative predictive value
because they're that direct measure of
accuracy
to the thing we care about the
unfortunate problem is that
ppv and npv are calculated
as interactions between the
characteristics of the test and
sensitivity and specificity
and the infection rate in the population
that's being tested
or in the case of an individual um the
prior probability that that person has
the disease
it's very rare that we actually know uh
with some accuracy what the infection
rate is in a population being tested
and it's impossible to quantify
somebody's prior probability of
infection when they walk in the door for
the test
but that doesn't mean that all is lost
here
this is a pretty statistically literate
audience we've probably all
had the example when you were learning
bayes rule about this
curious result from diagnostic testing
where when you apply bayes rule
uh the probability that you have the
disease given
uh that you got a positive result is uh
maybe a lot lower than we expected it to
be
but i think where we've failed in sort
of statistics education is to draw a
line from that curious result
to what actually happens in the real
world and why are diagnostic tests
still reliable under certain conditions
on the other hand if i can uh wag a bit
of a finger
at some in the biomedical community i've
had conversations with folks where
they're just blindly accepting the test
result and seeing it as this is the gold
standard and my clinician judgment or
other factors don't matter if you've got
a positive result
so what i wanted to do is spend some
time here
and give us some intuition about what
these numbers actually mean and how they
play off
each other so looking at this chart on
the left
we've got positive predictive value on
the y-axis
on the x-axis we have prevalence the
infection rate or for an individual it's
that
prior probability of infection so
for a population you know it's the
infection rate
and that ppv is going to be basically an
average of the positive predictive value
across everyone who
you gave a test to that's not really
helpful again in that clinical setting
because you care i care about me
and i want to know do i have the disease
given that this
this test result came back so think
about it this way
if i have no uh prior reason to believe
that i've been infected i've been
staying home i haven't been seeing
people
nobody that has been around me has been
diagnosed with coronavirus i'm showing
no symptoms
my prior probability of infection is
quite low i'm on the left side of this
chart
however um if i've been going out
huge parties a bunch of people i know uh
all got sick and i got positive
diagnoses and i'm starting to develop a
cough
i'm now moving way right on that where
uh that test diagnostic is going to be
pretty conclusive
i actually lived through this recently i
went in for a physical
my doctor ordered an antibody test um
and i you know i told him hey doc i have
very little prior reason to believe
uh that i've been exposed to coronavirus
and i walked him through all these
statistics
and he said you know that's that's all
fine and good just humor me and i said
okay fine if it comes back positive
we're going to do another test because
i think it's going to be a false
positive so lo and behold
i get a positive result for the igm
antibody but a negative result for the
igg antibody
and so taken at face value if igm is
positive but igg is negative
that could uh be indicative of of
current infection not past infection
okay so i started out very close to zero
on the x-axis
i get a positive result so what that
means is now my posterior probability of
infection is probably about 40 percent
um i'm gonna go schedule a pcr test and
if that comes back positive i'm starting
at about the 40
line so if it comes back positive that
is really strong evidence that i'm
infected
uh in my case the pcr test came back
negative that was in fact a false
positive but
i hope the little anecdote has helped
sort of marry the math
with what's actually happening in the
real world when we do diagnostic testing
very similar result for the negative
predictive value
except now when the prevalence of the
disease is low or the prior probability
is low
negative results in the absence of other
information are pretty
pretty strong evidence of not being
infected
but when you start getting into areas
where
lots of the population has the disease
or you've got a patient who has a very
strong
prior for being sick then the negative
results themselves can be suspect
so turning our attention back to the
fda's website if you're a public health
official
um you know you want to know about these
tests you don't want to comb through all
of
these pdf files we built
this portion of the application so that
you can sort and filter that information
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
demoing that just just for the sake of
expediency but i am going to show you
this part of the tool that focuses on
test accuracy in terms of ppv and npv
and lets you interact with all of the
tests that have received fda
emergency youth author authorization
for uh molecular pcr and antigen but we
haven't done
antibody tests and so with that comes
the
most nerve-racking part where i have to
do a live demo and hope nothing crashes
so here like i said covidtestdb.com is
this
sortable list if you're a public health
official
in the biomedical field there might be a
lot of relevant information here about
which tests are compatible with
equipment that you may have in your lab
but i'm going to go straight to the
performance
so covettestdb.com performance will drop
you into this application
it'll start off in a document that
we wrote that covers a lot of the
material that i've already done in the
presentation so far
but if you go into this results tool
here's where you can start browsing
tests this picture should look familiar
um i just want to say that that
something i glossed over before is this
shaded region here
that's a 95 confidence interval so like
i said we we pulled the data from
the fda's website out of these the data
they report
the manufacturers reported these are
finite sample sizes so
we didn't just calculate the expected
ppv in npv but we could also put
a 95 confidence interval on it
and so here you can select test there's
dozens of manufacturers
i'm going to go with with abbott here
they're pretty popular
and then from there you can select
whichever tests they've submitted to the
fda
and here you'll notice we've got one
test but then multiple
sources where the source says find dx so
the
a couple speakers ago we had a couple
speakers from find
we've been supplementing the data that
we're pulling out of the pdfs with
data that find is collected that's often
um you know
independent evaluations that maybe have
larger sample sizes than
what the manufacturer reported to the
fda but here i'm going to go with this
uh abbott uh a g card this is a
an antigen rapid test it's received a
bit of press recently
on the left you've got this positive
predictive value chart for
the abbot antigen test on the right
we've included data
from an influenza rapid diagnostic test
the purpose here is so that you can see
how does my coronavirus test compare to
a flu test that is you know used and
trusted
uh regularly so you can see the overall
shape of these curves are the same
like i said this this uh uh the main
properties here are properties of
testing for relatively rare conditions
not anything unique to coronavirus but
the coronavirus test has a much wider
confidence interval because there's
more data backing up the influenza test
if you scroll down for those that may be
less mathematically inclined
we've got these text boxes here that say
for the selected prevalence level if you
give a hundred thousand tests here's how
many we would expect to come back
positive
of those here's how many we would expect
to be true positives and false positives
we've got the same thing for negative
predictive value including the text here
and you can update that dynamically with
this slider
so i went from five percent prevalence
to 10 percent
and the text here has now updated so uh
you can then use that to explore
how you think uh these tests might
perform based on the data that's been
reported
uh and conditions that you believe may
affect you as an individual or
the population in your jurisdiction and
the last thing i'll point out is that
you can also download the data that's
backing up these charts
um so that you could do your own
analyses uh with the data that we
calculated
uh across the the whole range of
possible
uh infection rates here so with that
i've got a couple minutes left so i'm
going to bring us home
um you're going to see a lot of charts
like this
in the tool and basically what happened
is in
in the rush to get these diagnostic
tests out to market you know we're in an
emergency people need to move fast
what the manufacturers have gone with
have been very small
sample sizes and and often what are
called um
uh uh like spiked samples so
uh they're contrived samples so rather
than being taken from a person that
they've confirmed has coveted 19 they've
then spiked
a sample with it and so you know we see
30 positive samples 30 negative samples
all perfectly classified it doesn't mean
the test is bad or the data is bad it
just means that we don't have enough
data to really say for sure how
accurate this is um this project is
still in in active development
so you know i'd uh encourage everyone to
to that might be inclined to get
involved
check out uh copatestdb.com
covatestdb.com performance if you have
questions comments feature requests
want to help uh with data uh you can
email us covatestdb
bnx.org or you can check out our github
repository there
uh you know uh forecast on github open
up a feature request
a big team went into this that cut
across several business units at
inquitel so big thanks to them
uh and that's all my time thank you so
much thank you
tommy and he didn't disappoint with the
tweed jacket you followed through in
your word
all right i think we could all agree
covet is a very important thing we've
all been discussing
back in april when we went virtual for
the meetup very first talk was noam ross
talking about some of the math behind
epidemiology and the next month was
romney crispin talking about the the
data sources
so i think as a data community we could
all hopefully be helpful with
the this chronovirus outbreak so
that brings us up to